there's no problem right now that people
that look at the world like me are
observing that would be better under
Donald Trump the war in the Middle East
will be prosecuted in a much less
favorable way in a much more aggressive
um and bloody way to the Palestinians in
Gaza uh than it already is been and what
we're seeing over there right now is ter
ridiculous murder right crazy so um just
all over the place but it would be worse
under Trump trump while he was in office
uh you could make an argument stoked
some of these tropes uh no they he he
stok some of these fires he he some of
these tensions arose under him he made
the decision geopolitically to move the
embassy um uh to Jerusalem and recognize
Jerusalem as the capital of Israel right
which was a
leld point of contention between uh you
know Israel and the West Bank like who
runs who has Jerusalem everybody had
just said kind of we're leaving that on
the table we're not trying to figure
that out we're it's it's a place that
nobody kind of owns you got talk about
Jordan West all that stuff and Trump was
like no no no no uh Jerusalem is the
cultural and political Center of Israel
he moved it there and not very many
other places in the world went along
with um him doing that the reality of it
is that he did that to Signal just how
staunch an ally he is of not just Israel
but of bib Netanyahu I want to make sure
I say this any criticism that I have of
Israel is of Israel as a state right any
criticism that I have of any state is of
that state as a state right people are
diving deep into some
pretty uh obvious anti-Semitism MH
and these things are being conflated but
if you are talking about a country and
it's geopolitical actions it's economic
actions it's human rights violations or
human rights violations that have been
committed against them in J in October
7th one of the worst terrorist attacks
we've ever seen you have to talk about
it in a sanitized intellectual way and
the reality is there's a geopolitical
Advantage for the United States to have
an ally where Israel is situated for
them to have a country that has some
semblance of democracy and to blindly
support and to blindly support it not
because they believe in Israel its
people its freedom its
self-determination or the freedom of the
self-determination of anybody else in
that region but because they believe in
their own and it's our own interests
that are their own interest at heart
it's being able to check up on Iran Iran
and being able to have an ally there and
so you'll send them as many apachi
helicopters as they need $3.3 billion a
year so when you're talking about like
what you think a country should be able
to do and what they should what they
should do you're talking about how you
look at the world and the way I look at
the world is through things that have
been deprived of me when I was a kid in
Baton Rouge which is freedom justice
access to Food Water Health Care um
environmental justice uh H one person
one vote um having your life matter
those are things that when I'm
consistently burying people where I'm
from that I do not see being reflected
in certain situations all over the world
right and that's the way I look at the
world I don't look at the world through
America first right I don't look at the
world through uh the lens of what's good
for us is the most important thing to me
I look at the world through the lens of
are people getting what they need do
people have what they need particularly
in this case I'm asking America to be
the the police for the entire world
particularly in this case America's
involved yeah very much involved without
being involved right America's involved
so if America's involved and you know
three of every dollar that I have or
going to the defense department whatever
the number is probably more than that um
then what I want to know is that the
people in charge have values and beliefs
about the value and sanctity of human
life that align with mine well the only
candidate that's running that is Cornell
West that shares those I feel like cuz
everybody else I feel like is very much
that's what I mean it's not a Biden
thing it's not a trump thing it's an
American an American that's that's I
think that's the most the most
bipartisan [__] ever support way here's
here's the deal and the killing of
Jeffrey and it's like it's it's like
[__] great but here's the thing this is
what I'm saying I'm saying is this I'm
saying that there I have a problem with
they're being with with having allies no
problem with America being like like in
a cultural or economic or even a
military alliance with
Israel the the problem becomes when
things are being rubber stamped that as
an American C citizen I think go against
our stated morals and goals Val the the
the values of the country that have
never been upheld or things that go
against mine right and I'm allowed to
say hey you know what I want everybody
to be safe I want everybody to feel safe
in their own home I love the fact that
there's a place where Jews can go and
they can feel at home and they can feel
safe I want everybody to have that but
at the same time what I want is for
power in the world to be responsible
that's it that's beautiful beautifully
said yeah look we out out I gotta say
something real quick before I
go I'm [__] with cactus tea and
everything that you're doing baby thanks
my mixtape is coming soon Cactus tea
mixtape coming soon yep Joe Rogan NW
situation I'm I'm I'm I'm by the end of
the week when is this dropping uh
probably Friday okay so by next Friday
by next Friday you going to be Donald
Trump wow cuz I'mma write this headline
I'mma doctor this
headline I'm going go they're very fine
people I'mma find I'mma find all the
other stuff you did for some sub assets
I got you now I [__] with you big time
all right appreciate you brother yeah